[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is Abby
Jacobson I still we recorded it today I
still kind of can't believe she came on
she's one of those people that the few
times I've seen her out and about I get
Starstruck I get nervous but she was so
so delightful this is always a treat
when we reach that frequency of kind of
like a sleepover or a friend hang
instant friends kind of vibe I'm gonna
say it instant friends kind of vibe
really enjoyed our chat so awesome
definitely check out A League of Their
Own which is on Amazon Prime right now
Val and I are currently watching it it
is as Abby says a reimagining it's not a
reboot or a remake it's a reimagining
and it's incredible and she's incredible
in it so definitely check that out a
couple things for me to plug as well I
have my Largo show here in La go to
Largo dashla.com for tickets to that
always awesome October 9th and November
3rd are the next two hope to see you out
there they've been so awesome Neil
Brennan at the last one we've had Sarah
Silverman I can't say who but we're
definitely going to have a very big
guest in October pretty excited about
that on October 9th uh
largo-la.com for tickets to that uh and
I'm going on tour it's the pet homes
where were we tour boom art by Katie
Fishel uh we I sounded like David Brent
on the office up by Katie Fishel not bad
I'm going to be in Toronto Atlantic City
New Jersey Boston Chicago San Francisco
Portland Seattle Atlanta Charlotte and
Washington D.C we may be adding some
more dates right now the tickets are out
on petehomes.com are Toronto Atlantic
City and Boston because those are the
ones that are on sale but as they become
available we'll be adding them so
Chicago hope to see you out that's going
to be at the Den that's a full weekend
so I'll be there all weekend hope to see
a lot of weirdos out there it's going to
be truly truly great truly truly great
couple things to plug if you like this
show the best thing to do we don't have
a patreon or anything like that just try
a pizza pick just try some of the
products that I love and swear by like
magic mind it's funny Abby actually
drinks a magic mind in this episode
which was not planned here they are a
sponsor but here she drinks one on the
air and she loved it because I love it I
absolutely am so into magic mind it's
not an energy drink I don't mess with
energy drinks I don't do great with high
levels of caffeine magic mind only adds
about 35 milligrams of caffeine in it
it's like having a green tea or
something like that pretty mild on the
caffeine level has adaptogens which are
naturally occurring compounds that help
round out the edges of stress so this is
something you take with your coffee if
you're drinking coffee in the morning
that's gonna round out and smooth out
that that jolt you get from caffeine and
make it more productive more sustainable
dialed in this isn't something that gets
you jacked up it makes you dialed in
it's a little shot like I say this in
the episode I always feel like The
Witcher when I'm drinking a little
Elixir because that's what it is it's a
magical Elixir that makes you focus
better on your work be more creative and
drink less coffee which is great for a
lot of reasons your sleep your health
lots of stuff I'm just going to say
generally your health it's got a mix of
12 functional ingredients including
matcha nootropics that help you focus
and adaptogens that help you fight off
stress can be take taken for a daily I
take it sometimes twice daily to be
honest for a sharper mind steady energy
immune support and less stress you get
30 percent more done on average five to
seven hours of thirty percent more
productivity after drinking and I can
attest to that I sometimes have it
around 10 a.m it's still in my system
several hours later and it's not a
jacked up feeling it's just a you brain
has what it needs energy wise Focus wise
it's truly incredible it's changed my
life magic mind is the daily morning
drink
for creators entrepreneurs and
Freelancers athletes have Gatorade now
creators have Creator Aid don't expect
wired expect dialed in helps fight off
procrastination brain fog fatigue and
some ADD symptoms getting you into that
sweet sweet Flow State after three to
seven days of continuous use it gets
easier to get into that flow State
easier the more you use it the better it
works it is a Creator's best friend you
will fall in love with this as I have I
promise it is incredible and I actually
have a special offer for listeners for
weirdos from our friends at magicmine
all you have to do is go to
www.magicmind.com weird and use our
discount code at checkout weird to get a
limited 20 off your first order that's
magicmind.com weird news promo code
weird to get a limited 20 off your first
order and try the world's first
productivity drink honestly a super
secret weapon in my creative life
speaking of secret weapon this right
here that you're seeing me wear if
you're watching the video version this
is my Apollo neuro if you guys listen to
the show you guys know I swear by this
Val swears by this and there's no
product maybe magic mind it's tied for
first that I tell people about just in
regular life they see it I tell them
about it deliver delivers gentle almost
sub-perceptual vibrations directly into
your nervous system because that is the
language that your nervous system speaks
touch this is basically like a wearable
hug that helps you fight stress and
recover from stress can help you relax
focus and be more productive a wearable
hug for your nervous system using touch
therapy to help you feel safe and in
control I actually left uh the house
this was two mornings ago got quite a
ways from the house realized I forgot my
Apollo turned around and came back and
got it that's how important it is and
last night I did sets uh stand up and as
I was falling asleep it was hard for me
to fall asleep I realized I didn't my
Apollo had run out of battery I charged
it wait 10 minutes
put it back on that's how much I rely on
it to lull me into sleep if all it did
was help me fall asleep I would still be
singing its Praises but it also helps me
wake up helps me ease into social
situations that would have otherwise
made me anxious helps me be clear and
focused when I'm working helps me
recover from a workout or from a
stressful conversation with my parents
helps me meditate there's a meditation
and mindfulness setting sometimes I use
it when I'm not meditating just to kind
of feel a little bit more Zen but when I
use it when I'm meditating I go so much
deeper so much more easily and at night
I put on relax and unwind when we're
watching TV before I know it I'm
starting to nod off get in bed put it on
sleep and renew and if I get up in the
middle of the night hit these two
buttons reruns the program and helps
lull me back to sleep it is actually
training your nervous system to cope
with stress better over time the more
you use it the better it works and it's
not I always say this it's not woo-woo
they don't sell these in Crystal shop
perhaps this is science it's
specifically Neuroscience it was
developed by a neuroscientist and a
board-certified psychiatrist who had
been studying the impacts of chronic
stress in humans for nearly 15 years and
Apollo's effects on stress sleep
cognitive performance and Recovery have
been proven in multiple clinical trials
and real world studies and you can try
it with 10 off by going to
apollonuro.com weird that's Apollo
n-e-u-r-o.com slash weird for 10 off and
to show your support of this show all
right everybody enjoy Abby Jacobson be
sure to check out A League of Their Own
and hope to see you on the road uh you
got those dates go to Pete homes if you
want to come see me do stand up
petehomes.com in the meantime enjoy Abby
Jacobson get into it and we're started I
mean this is a very casual show if
that's okay I just don't want you to
feel like we're bugging you
like bugging your secret thoughts on
weather
no no yeah
we can edit it out yeah this is your
episode and it's a safe space you have
several weeks and then take these off I
was just gonna say
no no think of it as like a sleepover do
you want a blanket no no
I don't know how you are yeah yes that's
that's it you're the only guest no one
does that Ryan holiday just did it and
the whole time he was like this it's
like a really deep you must have to you
have to but it's supposed to be like a
it's not really by Design but I love
sleepovers
yeah and doesn't this feel like a
sleepover I haven't had one in a while
right I mean except like with
my person I'm with of course yeah that's
the Perma sleepover yeah and with Val
well that's that's why I didn't uh hug
or shake or anything you as our baby has
a cold so she was in her bed last night
and I actually think that's my favorite
thing in the world I would imagine it's
and it has to be for her imagine oh yeah
you're you're two number one people oh
my God like let me in right yeah it's
cuddle puddle yeah and I was just
reading this um it's so embarrassing
when I'm reading a book and I know
you're a reader I was listening to you I
try all the time tell me wait why'd you
say it's embarrassing that you're
reading no it's embarrassing that I will
mention a book because I read multiple
books at once oh you're like so
embarrassing I was reading a book
it is it's a humble bag you know I'm a
reader but if you can manage to read I
do want to talk about that with you but
anyway this book called tribe which I'm
really enjoying uh talks about how like
parents and babies we're primates we
share 98 of our DNA with chimpanzees but
this whole like sleep training thing oh
yeah they're like that would have been
considered child abuse for the past
million years of human evolution like
not to leave a baby there's like nowhere
to
where would they have left the baby it
would have been like right there always
right absolutely which I don't even
think would count because and he is
making the case and by the way I know
this is a sensitive subject to so to
those parents that are sleep training I
understand I get it just kind of making
this other point he said that we hold
our children skin to skin like 16 of the
time whereas our ancestors were like 90
90 of the time around there and I'm just
like when I do it it does sort of feel
sort of like cheaty like I'm being too
lovey to the baby but it also feels like
the best thing in the world see I don't
have any kids yet yeah you can't imagine
like I can't imagine you're being
bombarded with what to do how to do it
all the different ways from
like internet uh books and friends who
just did it and parents and do it right
to your face your parents will do it to
your face but
the sleep training I have friends doing
that too and I like
I I don't know how you choose what to do
well Val that's my wife and I are super
softies and we're just going with that
instinct so they're like cry it out
thing just wasn't on the table I mean I
didn't even have a dog and I remember
doing that with like a it's not the same
but like no it is it's like a crate
training you're like I can't we can't do
this we had that with Brody we were like
for some reason I got in my mind because
I had never had a dog before that I was
like dogs need to sleep in crates
otherwise I don't know what I thought he
would do like mangle the sofas the same
thing where you're like well he needs to
know this and then once he's trained
then you can like let exactly it's like
thank you and by the way a lot of the
same shame stuff applies I remember my
Instagram that we got the dog then like
10 days later I was really having like a
like a panic that we had made a mistake
with the dog we did not get we still
have this dog but I felt trapped and
obviously there's like a social element
to that it's like you you didn't get a
rescue or are you even considering
giving the dog away I'm ashamed to admit
that so when it comes to breastfeeding
sleep training what do you feed them I
know it's insane it's insane but you
would like to you kind of kids yeah I'm
sorry there's a personal question but
you can always you can always just say
pass no no no no no
I do I'm trying to kind of not see this
other thing I'm like I'm kind of like I
kind of gotta I kind of gotta do it soon
yeah but I I do want kids you would you
carry the the baby
I think because that's the violence
that's your that's your close process
and I'm going to give you a stand-up tip
ice cream cone ice cream cone with your
microphone okay no no no and if there
was we just won't use that shot
um
carrying the baby I think like
exactly but I think one yeah yeah at
least one you would do one well I would
do one and you might have two yeah
that's a really cool well I don't know I
I don't know but I do not have this is
not a legal document yeah I'm just
curious that process first of all is a
huge undertaking like they say like I'm
not like a huge astrology person or
anything like that but they say it shows
up on a chart like a death and Val will
say that they're like a huge event like
like a death in that sense you mean like
wait you mean looking at the mom's chart
or looking at the mom's chart oh like
that it's like
bam you're somebody else because it'll
show up when someone were to look at my
thing before I were to have it or no no
I don't think it works that way but okay
I didn't understand what you're saying I
don't even know I used an example that I
can't even fully back up what I'm saying
let me let me bring it back to you yeah
yeah Val would say that it it's this
rite of passage oh yeah which this
culture is severely starving for so
there's something really cool and I and
like like Freudian pouch Envy stuff I
saw what val did giving birth to the
baby and I saw that she did something
impossible
and then showed up on the other side of
it so it must she must be stronger than
she thought she would you know what I
mean like that's a invaluable experience
oh yeah that's yeah and I feel
a lot of my friends a lot of my close
girlfriends have recently had kids and
I'm just sort of like
wow yeah like it is huge huge huge it's
and very scary I was just gonna say
terrifying yeah I I had a lot of moments
as the as the non holding the baby
partner whereas like and Val knows this
so [__] thank God like I I would have
nightmares like Junior oh yeah like I'd
be so
scared
is it David no it's not Katie it's not
Danny DeVito it's but shouldn't it be
Tom
but shouldn't it wait isn't there one
where it's like twins that's twins
isn't Junior
they brought him back because I was like
just that's casting I was like they
their [__] there was one okay but that's
Junior two is that what they're trying
to do with the rock and Kevin Hart I
just realized
I just realized yes yeah that makes a
lot I didn't think of that either
there's nothing new
who just like read I just re-imagined a
thing there is like nothing new we can't
call it a reboot it's not really a
reboot it is a reimagining I try not to
because people are like very upset are
they or just like people get really
upset when you're going to reboot their
thing so
imagine yes reimagining is great by the
way it shows fantastic I think I didn't
mean to I didn't mean to that was just
an organic segue but there is nothing
new we all saw it coming a mile away you
came in here talking about the weather
and you kept being like yeah this
weather's in the leg of its own it's
like stop it you're a media Mogul and a
promotion machine she mentioned it three
times this Craftsman is
you said you had to take a Pina Davis
when you went to the bathroom
he said I'm sorry to be a real Madonna
right now this is ridiculous
[Laughter]
all right that's so good if I was doing
that that's really
really that's great I gotta like get a
couple more no more puns I gotta take a
Pina Davis
um but that is interesting I didn't
consider that people must be a little
protective because it's like a two-hour
childhood memory and it's like it's one
of my favorite movies is why we did it
but it is people were are like
why do you need to remake like why like
I think in general a lot of people are
just like angry at remakes like why
can't there be anything new what like
Hollywood has no original ideas anymore
sure all that I don't get really upset
like you know the those that sector of
the internet I just have a I don't feel
that way that strongly to comment about
anything yes in that way like I kind of
just don't understand
I am I think I have anger in my life but
like I don't feel like I need to put it
on
the internet love yeah maybe also I'm
not a huge course sorry to keep
mentioning astrology now where they're
called miracles of course do you know A
Course in Miracles no it doesn't matter
it was a book that a woman channeled it
doesn't matter it's interesting a lot of
people love it okay
um I love the the practices about it I
keep looking at your toe I don't want
you to think I'm like a weirdo like
checking out your feet colorful
don't say it no no like I don't know if
you ever paint your nails but see this
my daughter when I when I if I got a
pedicure and I like immediately ruined
it and then like with the shoe and
haven't fixed it so shame sorry shame uh
a lot of Shame it's recently started
getting pedicures and flippy flop season
by the way all of our Dad's feet are so
disgusting your dad my dad what are
these [__] feet you need to start
fixing that [__] now right I'm 43. it's
right around now that they're starting
but it's to turn into Star Wars we
started going aren't you a little bit
like wow
this is like a little AB life-changing
right it's everything it's self-care
women have had self-care cornered not
wrongly here let me say let's put a pin
in self-care just yeah yeah and of
course in Miracles yeah I want to see
your course yeah I love this teaching it
goes you're not angry for the reason you
think you are is one of the like things
you're supposed to yeah it's not about
this is not about this and they actually
because it's a spiritual thing they go
down they go you're angry because you
think you live in a meaningless universe
that's so it just goes like stop it's
not A League of Their Own no I'm like
you're not really are you like this is
not about us redoing this movie it's
absolutely not no and then the third one
again and then we're gonna go back to
self-care I'm more excited about that
but the third one is God did not create
a meaningless Universe I know that uses
religious language but it's like this
like whatever you believe yes yes you
could say the universe is not
meaningless meaningless even if you
don't believe that it's helpful to say
it and and lean towards looking for the
evidence that it's not me yes you know
what I'm saying we'll get to that later
unless you had something nope
I just wanted to really like A Course in
Miracles into the the subreddit about
people who made a league is such like a
um I have a hard time with the internet
I think because get off it makes me feel
terrible if I ever like just dive right
below the surface of of anything like
that I'm like wow I can't handle this
well what's your relationship with it
like with social media and all that on
good for you Twitter okay no I'm I'm not
on hey good for you Twitter I'm just on
Instagram okay yes that's so like that's
like the last the last one and I'm
really I really wasn't on it very much
at all until the show
came back and then I I just feel this
like I feel like it's part of the uh
press yes like it's part of
Mark like I I feel a responsibility like
I have to sort of Market it to whatever
people would have watched the Broad City
would like I just feel like a very yeah
that's part of the game now no you you
wrote a wonderful book when I was doing
my book I was and my book is all about
like not really but it's kind of hinting
that social media and stuff is bad and
yet I'm on social media being like hey
you gotta check out this is so cute you
have to except me too I feel like I'm
like I think there's a part in the book
where I'm talking about this because we
all feel that but
it's vicious like you need it it's there
it's part of the marketing
stuff well it's like um McDonald's or to
pick a fast food chain that might not be
good for you you need food so they they
have the like hook you need connection
right not just promotion but you kind of
like talk about a million years of of
human biology we need to check in with
the community with the tribe see where
we are yeah I don't mean to say
especially women but women tend to lean
even more communal than men so we're
having like that this uh yanking us
towards it but this is look this is too
heavy-handed but like I was just talking
to Mike Birbiglia yesterday I was
telling him I have this bit about social
media and how I think it's funny that
everybody thinks that if you were in One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest you would be
the person that wouldn't take the pills
right because they make everyone crazy
right so you throw them over your head
or you yeah yeah poor Katie's heard me
say this a million times or you put them
under your tongue or whatever but here's
the rub some of those pills are Xanax
right you know so that's what I mean
like some of the pills are promoting
your book right like some of them are
knowing your friends had a baby yes so
there's some I'm using xanax's meaning
you'll like it yeah and then there's the
crazy making ones as well the good Xanax
yeah xanax.com weird for 10 added to
your bill at the end of the program but
it still supports the show please do it
I'm just kidding
um but like what's interesting about
that is I'm trying to say like [__]
social media it's the pills that makes
everyone crazy because it reduces
reality into a binary it's either good
or bad either Abby look you look hotter
it's like what a piece of [__] or like
like go like yeah go [__] yourself go
[__] yourself nobody nobody is gonna
you're in like a wild ride that's right
yeah and don't get me started on how the
human brain is uh preconditioned to hold
on to negative things ten times more
than than positive this is like I like
the good I don't process
a good thing
but I will take like the one of course
it's terrible it's a drug yeah it's a
it's like I'm looking for it you are I
am I just I'm only saying that because I
am yeah it's like it's whenever I engage
or when I mean again whenever I actually
look at the feedback it is to find a
badma Yep this or the bad ones it's as
much as close as I can come to
understanding
and I don't think cutting is like the
weirdest thing in the world said this
too yes like I feel like it is self yeah
you're hurting yourself it's something
in your mouth that won't heal because
you keep tonguing it yep to quote Fight
Club you want them to Fight Club hi I'm
19.99. yeah but like you or like
something on your body you just won't
let heal that I can relate way more to
that yeah Val's always like will you
stop yeah it's because you want you want
that Rush that feeling of
indignation or self-righteousness you
want to be like you make a TV show do
you not you know like all that sort of
stuff but yeah and everybody that
listens to this show has heard this
before but think of how I feel I've said
it so many times but it's velcro Teflon
is the theory velcro is if I say I don't
even want to say a fake negative thing
but if I say something negative it
velcros to you but if I say which I did
not only is it legal their own
incredible and I envy those like
sculpted shows because the show I made
crashing was great obviously but when I
watch it I'm not like it wasn't Wes
Anderson it was it was improvised and it
was more like
where you're like
yes but then but then I watched League
of Their Own you must have had the same
feeling and you're like ah I'm finally
in something that's like
we know how we're gonna shoot this it's
a special shot it's slow motion I know
you were there I'll tell you what it
feels like as a viewer crashing you cut
to the wide it's a it's just a different
process it's like it's like doing going
on stage and doing it's not this because
crashing is not fully improvised
brunson's not fully improvised but it's
like you go on stage and you're like
here we go like whatever hap like let's
use whatever happens and like the energy
versus going on stage and doing a
scene a bonsai tree yes like a dramatic
like not that leaked turmeric but it's
like a planned like scene like
and both can go but yeah very different
but even the way it's shot there's a lot
of deliberate and beautiful Val was like
is this shot on film and I was like
nowhere no no there's no way but it
looks that good it doesn't have that
like digital piece of [__] uh so many
digital things look terrible but like it
looks beautiful it has like slow motion
stuff it has like I don't know like this
seems uh there's a lot of scenes where
like they let the X Factor play out like
there's some sort of quirky performance
and it plays out in one meaning you're
not building it by cutting between
crashing what I was going to say was
like sometimes would cut across the
street because it was the only coverage
we had that riff in yeah yeah yeah so it
would be a scene like this and then for
some reason it's over the freeway and
it's me being like talk about the Flash
and then it comes back in A League of
Their Own has more of a and I'm not
putting my show down or Broad City shows
that are building it like that but but A
League of Their Own has that like it
feels storyboarded like someone new
like I keep thinking of that scene where
you're running out on the field and how
joyful that is and how cool that is or
even the opening where you're chasing
the train very deliberate yes was that
harder to do because or did you like the
constraints it must have been driving
like one of those old model T's at
Disneyland where there's the track and
you can't really move yeah I mean there
are so many
different kind
S I did feel similar things on Broad
City that you probably had on crashing
too where like we had like crazy Warners
that like you had to be like we were
very intentional with the way that we
made that show too this was just like so
much bigger
in terms of like budget and scope and
it's an hour and it's period And I think
like visually all everything already
puts us in like a more filmic
environment so costumes but the the
Model T like all the cars and everything
is like you're like where the [__] I'm
like I'm not in my usual yeah
space right now yeah and um but the
limitations of like we still just ha it
it was coverage wise it was like we net
we hardly ever did Cross coverage and
like so it was so much
more intentional and
Limited in terms of I'm trying to say
like
there wasn't as yeah there wasn't as
much freedom
because we needed to get certain
coverage in a way I don't know if I may
if I'm articulating oh I'm understanding
you that's exactly what I was asking is
like you're Cross coverage for those who
don't know you're shooting it two ways
and that you know this way and that way
at the same time which lenses which is
what we're comedic scene exactly because
that's what we're doing right now yes
because we're gonna riff you have both
that's right whereas if you're in league
and
Darcy and I are in a scene it's not done
cross cross so you're it's really hard
to like re-riff that's right you know
forget it get it again even if someone
wrote it down so right so you we might
have had it in a two shot and so you're
always like it I felt like it limited
the comedy for me but enhanced
everything else so you do have these
like more Grand sweeping things that I
think make it maybe feel like it's shot
on film or something but
I don't know I'm like I this is a I'm
rambling now but yeah it's very
different oh you're answering my
question perfect very different and in
terms of like arcing a season like Broad
City we didn't
story-wise didn't start really arcing
the characters emotionally until like
the fourth and fifth seasons and this is
like fully
arced and and built to be
uh twists and turns and this and that
like red city is like a day every
episode is a day and you can watch them
out of order kind of and this should not
be watched out of order it's very
crafted in that way I the letter I don't
want to spoil it but the letter it's a
letter it's in your notebook but it's a
letter that you're writing to your uh
husband husband yeah I'm like concerned
for your character it's a boyfriend
right it's a boyfriend I got it you got
it I was like I envied the drama of that
I was like how simple
I feel like shows these days have to
like hook you real quick but they I
don't want to feel like I'm being hooked
real quick there's certain shows where
I'm like this is just a pot boiler
they're just going like but
I don't even want to name the show I'm
thinking about but like they just know
the devices that will make you want to
see right who shot the arrow like just
like human yeah yeah but like this show
puts stuff in play that you want to see
how it works out without me feeling like
this is just to get me to watch the next
one that's good yeah no it's also so
interesting to talk about a letter like
I'm
I think you too like
like I'm used to writing right now so
the limitations of story right now
so much of a drama and conflict in our
present day unfortunately involves is
lost because we have a cell phone oh but
God forget it it's like you can't you
just made me no one's late no one's like
you can't like everything that you can
can happen is like well they would be
able to text them or anything about the
directions and so with that it's like
this letter is yes so important because
it's like
it's not I'm not spoiling anything in
the pilot I write this letter and it's
sort of like very important whatever's
in the letter and all this but you can't
a letter now is so
it's just an interesting thing to
someone doesn't show up in 1943 is like
they're gone yeah they're gone yeah
where are they skadoodle that's why they
had so many ways to say yeah she hit the
room she hit the bricks because
everybody was always disappearing yeah
yeah and also like not a it is a big
deal and not because like people must
have not shown up all the time and you
had to not think it was
that's right now if someone doesn't show
up and they don't pick up it's
something's they're gone they're dead
they're fully dead yeah that's right
like let's call someone else for 15
minutes and doesn't answer once I'm like
we need a call we need to call someone
and there's something that has to be
happy yeah but you're bringing me back I
was just talking to Birbiglia again same
phone call this was last night and I was
like on Saturday I try and do uh like
like a phone Sabbath I'm not Jewish but
no phone but it's a good it's a great
it's a great rule I don't do it and I am
Jewish
I'm Jewish shaming you yeah
yeah so I feel like I know I should you
could do that I know no it's not it's
it's really not for everybody meaning
there are times in my life that it
wasn't for me but now it's for me I feel
like I can do it and I do it and Mikey
was like I should do that too he said
that he went to the Comedy Cellar last
night but he forgot his phone and he
needed to ask someone uh to call an Uber
for him and he asked his friend they did
it happily but that need that was
created I said to him what did I say I
said like remembering my own life like
I'm Hemingway what did I say to him I
said yeah I said it went from a problem
that you would have just solved with
let's be honest a piece of technology
that does not love you right pretty
simple right but like really consider
that it doesn't give a [__] about you
food cooked by people who don't give a
[__] about you delivered by people who
don't give a [__] about you on a phone
that doesn't give a [__] about you
doesn't need to but it's kind of worth
noting yes now has been turned into a
friend it became something that and he
agreed I was like you might remember
that on your deathbed it's so small but
you go like remember that time that Abby
called me an Uber or she took care of me
and it was created by
not having your phone and we had so much
more of that need in in the 90s and
certainly what year is uh League of
Their Own 43 43 Good Year good year and
I know nothing about that year I know
kind of a lot but don't test me now oh I
will not I will absolutely not so you're
absolutely right the letter and when you
mail the letter this is what that
brought to mind how many breakups or or
like decisions that you didn't even mean
were you forced to stick to because of
the Heat of the Moment like that letter
these days you might just be a text and
maybe you just send it and now you have
to commit to it but you really had to
like think about it and stuff
I know I'm talking a lot but like I
really feel like I also would have it
lasts like
at least a week yes like it's not so
immediate things are not as immediate
because at least
anyone that wasn't living in the same
spot like communication yeah was very
different it was brought by Pony yeah
and then their response you kind of knew
you were getting like a thoughtful
response unless the handwriting was
insane and there was telling there was
telephones as well but telephones for
sure but who had time yeah yeah
but it is just
this is it's just different it is but
also I can remember like we can remember
not no cell phones which was like if
someone didn't pick up a landline no big
deal no big deal but also I remember my
mom like not being able to find me yeah
and truly I will never forget I was at a
baseball huh hilarious baseball there it
is all right we get it A League of Their
Own now it's streaming on Amazon Prime
included with Prime Membership
it was one of those things where she was
like I pictured you on the on the back
of a milk carton yeah like where like
now it's like you have a phone you have
a phone attached to you you're right
look this is what I was gonna say about
phone Sabbath is it is like being in the
90s for one day and what you notice is
a day is a lot richer than you remember
like if you're not con and let's be
honest sometimes it's great you're being
it's like a layer of frosting you're yep
it it keeps you from feeling unpleasant
things but also might be keeping you
from feeling some pleasant things but
like on those Saturdays I'm really
shocked at how
kind of crazy your inner life can be not
bad crazy because it's slow this is
misleading it's more like this life can
be so much slower slow the phones make
us everything go faster because you're
wasting time and then bring in coffee
which I'm drinking just a little bit of
you oh you're drinking I thought that
was a Seltzer Cold Brew I'm drinking a
cold beer you know I don't know if you
can tell I am
I'm I've only had one coffee do you need
I should have had a second coffee no I
think I'm doing okay do you want to
drink a magic mine is my favorite thing
a what it's a matter it's 35 milligrams
of caffeine so it's like drinking like a
green tea
matcha it also has nootropics and
adaptogens so do you know what
adaptogens are a little bit they round
out stress yeah they help you cope with
stress and nootropics help you think if
I give it to you yeah because you're a
writer you're gonna you're gonna get on
do you are you you're sponsoring now
yeah but I loved them before they were
sponsoring the show would you grab one
Katie sorry I truly as a writer you're
gonna love you I I drink matcha yep oh
they're like little guys oh yeah a
little Elixir from the show The Witcher
yeah
yeah you're gonna love
it I I know this seems like an ad this
is just real this is just me saying like
this is gonna make you you're gonna love
it okay it also works with your coffee
let me do that I'll have this much of
this and then I'm done oh okay I can't
okay I'm an anxious person
so if I have too much okay this is good
it's oh okay I was ready for you to be
like yeah they put honey and Stevia in
it and I think they're my friend James
bashara invented it you should just
shoot it I should okay maybe that is I'm
because I'm sipping it yeah it's
definitely a shoot
but
um it's also I can I use the phrase lady
like it or I'll just say it's very
dainty you're just taking a little bit
that's one of those where it's like
uncomfortable to sip I think they were
afraid as most people who sell matcha
are that it tastes like like moan grass
but this is uh this is totally workable
time to get that good stuff you really
imagine mine Pro I'm gonna say
but it wait I feel like I cut you off
we're going which I tend to do me too I
know it's okay it's okay it is okay I
kind of want to go back to your coffee
thing you can drink that much coffee
without spa and you should you know what
I have it don't taste spazzing it's
offensive I have major not major I ha I
do have anxiety so maybe it's bad that I
drink so much coffee but I'll have one
in the morning and then maybe a second
in the morning and then I'll have one at
like 2 30. are you looking like a 16
ounce like iced coffee no we're talking
like coffee at home like a Chemex cup of
coffee okay and then maybe another one
of those and then I'll maybe I'll do a
nice coffee later
what time is that 2 30 or 3. okay that's
not terrible this is also when I'm
mostly in a writing yeah yeah where am I
I need it so bad especially a zoom room
I can't even throw me out the window
like what season of it would Broad City
where you're like that's me in a zoom
writer's room where you're like hanging
on the building we wouldn't oh yeah oh
yeah I was like we would never know the
poster well we were mimicking like the
rock hanging off yeah what was let's
bring it back to that where he's like
hanging out of the and there's a
helicopter yeah yeah or Kevin Hart
hanging off his foot right on one
shoelace that's it that's it I got it
I'm fully supported
oh poor Kevin keep your shoe on
he uh he's so talented and all we talk
about is how short he is what a shame
I mean uh says a collective I do really
I do really like Kevin Hart is he great
have you ever no never I do really like
Kevin Hart oh no maybe I shouldn't say
this I love it edit it out if you don't
like it you know what and maybe just
fact check it I really actually love
Kevin Hart I love Alana and I wrote a
movie for him once that he didn't want
to do we wrote it but what we thought it
was great no no to something I left now
a voicemail and Kevin Hart was in it
thank you
hot riff Hot River I'm gonna give myself
the hot riff award he said no well like
it just wasn't the right movie well
probably because he was doing nine yeah
like he's there's like a huge movie star
no actually we wrote this movie which I
think is brilliant tell me it was and it
is a reboot it was you remember the film
The Bodyguard of course Whitney Houston
Kevin Costner yeah we wrote a new
version of The Bodyguard
with I think this is so funny Kevin Hart
Melissa McCarthy and Melissa McCarthy's
The Bodyguard yeah
funny right it's great Kevin Hart is a
rapper and needs a bodyguard but doesn't
they don't want The Bodyguard to look
like a bodyguard
and so she was sort of like this like X
like what if you picture McCarthy and
she's like what do you mean
what do you mean I don't look like a
bodyguard Oh I thought you meant what do
you mean like I've never heard of this
movie and I was like she might have
never heard it might remember God
no it got to her I know I'm like I'm
pretty sure it got to them what you were
saying though Melissa McCarthy isn't
gonna look like a bodyguard so she can
be close to him without like she would
be the unlikely person nearby and the
the poster is obviously her carrying
Kevin Hart out of like Kevin Costner
caring and and she's kind of like we're
back to co-sleeping that is like a
that's a baby
would be so fun like are you [__]
crazy yes I know I hate I hate when
ideas die I can't handle it but also
I've never liked I've never talked about
it it's kind of fun to talk about it
it's like that would have been a fun
movie it would have been great anyway
the one thing I don't love that I might
have heard wrong and maybe someone will
come at me about it probably on the
league subreddit yeah actually I really
don't ever want to go and look at I I
feel like I heard that he didn't feel
comfortable playing gay
oh in not in The Bodyguard but in some
in anything
which I feel in I feel just overall like
an actor isn't really a lot of things
that they play right
I wonder you know that's always just
like a interesting thing to know about
someone that they yeah remember Will
Smith pre-slap pre-slaps Mill pre-slap
Smith did he say is this him too
pre-slap Smith was in Six Degrees of
Kevin Bacon I'm just kidding it's called
Six Degrees of Separation yeah it was a
great film and he said pre-slap I have
to keep saying freestyle not that we
have to disown somebody for making a
mistake I'm just making but he he said
that one of the greatest uh regrets of
his career was doing the kiss there was
a gay a homosexual kiss it sounds words
to say homosexual it was a man-man kiss
with Will and he had it shot from behind
so I think he didn't actually do the
Smoochy smooch oh and he later said that
was one of the greatest regrets that he
didn't do it because it was like his
artistic career he was like what am I
what was I but he was on you know he he
wasn't there yet maybe Kevin's in a
similar yeah because I really
I do really like him
yeah that was so one thing that kind of
threw me it does are you looking it up
you don't have to what do you type in
Kevin Hart gay no but I also you know I
might I'm not really up to date on all
that stuff yeah I understand it doesn't
feel this doesn't feel like shots fired
no no I just I do really like I think he
seems like he's super talented and he
sure is yeah let's just pitch him a lot
of game movies
The Bodyguard was extraordinary it
actually wasn't but although I just
light up that's enough as if it was two
dudes
kind of kind of a good idea yeah all
right where were we oh self-care is one
of those self-care yeah yeah are you a
good self-care person not right now
what are you doing right now what are
you doing what's going on I need to get
I'm not I'm really good at self-care
when I'm in a routine and right now my
life is all I feel like I just
I just like the show just came out and
then I went on I did I went on vacation
okay which I haven't done in so long let
me guess where you went you're gonna
guess it because you went to Maui no
no is it because you went to Maui where
did you go I went to Italy I was gonna
say you feel Spain to me I was close to
Spain and Spain I went to Mallorca nice
yeah was it it was incredible I believe
it I've Never Been to Spain you should
you should go I believe it it's really
good towards the top of molest I'd never
been to Italy I'd Been to Spain
but very different I've been to
Barcelona but I'd never been I mean
Italy is um
that's what they say yeah it's great no
it's really great it's like everything
about it where where were you I was on
the coast
um on the west coast in Santa Monica
yeah
it's great Italian restaurant San Juan
um Buca di Beppo there you go great
family style yeah family salary just me
really hungry yeah either way I'll eat
seven chicken cutlets I don't care
you're in the west side it would be like
if you're I didn't go to Tuscany but
it's like Tuscany and like like the
coast
how is the driving did you take like a
car from the airport to where was it
nuts that's all I remember like we took
a car one way and it was like an hour
from the airport which was fine and then
we took a train the other way which was
nice but you didn't notice that the
driving was say different from the
western style no did you yeah last time
I went to Italy sorry privilege check
but last time I was in Italy Val and I
got in the cab or I actually think it
was a car like a like you know somebody
was hired meaning not just a yellow cab
off the street yeah and he was looking
at his phone and drive like the whole
way and we were just like it's like when
you're not sure if it's cultural and it
doesn't feel appropriate because
everyone was doing it it was sort of
like a guy was like in the lane it was
almost like he was driving where like
the lines were supposed to be in the
middle of the car yeah like when you're
when I was a kid I thought you made the
lines go underneath yeah I do remember
that good yeah and did you relax
I did you were able I read a whole book
you read a whole book I just have I had
been on such a not relaxing mode like
this show took
season one took like I mean we've been
writing it since 2018. wow and
production was like two and a half years
this shows are awesome sorry so I was
like I need when this when I when it
comes out I'm leaving yeah I'm getting
out of here getting out of here yeah
yeah and I wasn't as you were talking
about before I really wasn't on my phone
that much Tuscany style for two weeks I
read I read like a book did you read
please be tribe I read you would have so
much to talk about interesting like dark
book my year of rest but if you're like
the Bible yeah I read the Bible it's
really dark sort of Twisted
a lot of he comes back family tragic
yeah
so it ends with this weird prophecy the
ocean turns into blood took a turn takes
a turn it starts off kind of it's
actually this is the Bible it starts off
really fast the Genesis yeah yeah great
book a lot of twists that's the Cecil B
Demille stuff yeah yeah and then the
middle is real sleepy real sleepy stick
with it stick with it wait for Jesus
wait he's sort of the Jared Leto of the
story oh my God what it's so funny Jared
Leto was there where on the vacation
okay synchronicity note it
notharicity right when we got there he
was there
um he was at this hotel no yeah you saw
a letter well I mean like from so far he
was truly
it was like it was like on one of those
picturesque Italian
um it's not a beach it's like a rocky
Seaside yes where you can kind of you
just like take a swim yes like this
incredible area but it was shallow rocks
but he was in he was fully snorkel like
snorkeling on his own like no one else
was he was in a full wetsuit snorkeling
Plato yeah and and friends were with
said they had spoken to him and I mean
because I was like whoa can you even
like is there anything even to see right
here like because it's it was he was on
his own like he's just looking at his
own beautiful reflection in the mouth I
know but he's looking at his own eyes oh
my God I'm Jared Leto but apparently he
there were a lot of things to see down
in there yeah he's no dummy I actually
I'm gonna put this to you Jared Leto I
think I think people tease him a little
bit because he's he's so beautiful and
all these things so you assume he's
stupid or whatever I mean I don't know
what people are teasing him for but I I
catch Leto being kind of a funny thing
to say yeah Jared Leto
um I think he might be supremely happy
like I think I think he might be rocking
the best life I think he yeah he
it felt like a place he he went a lot
yeah and like I was like he knows
there's he knows I'm like what is he
looking at and like then I find out
there's like all this life right there
he's like yeah you gotta check this out
I think he I don't know like his full I
mean he'll always be Jordan Catalano to
me from my so-called life but I feel
like right now he does roles where
even if
it might not be a show that I'm like
obsessed with it does seem like he's
having fun he's like taking roles that
seem really fun yep so I'm like how's it
Gooch you know what I mean that and then
I did watch some of the
we work one where I'm like these are
like big characters that seem fun but I
don't want to put down Joseph Gordon Lev
but if you think it's just a foregone
conclusion that like a tech billionaire
or like upstart thing is like an easy
slam dunk roll I I wasn't as compelled
by super pumped as I was by we crashed I
didn't see the Joseph Gordon live at one
yeah it's not it's I saw it on an
airplane which is just sort of what yeah
yeah which I don't know why uh Brian
koppelman who wrote it and a lot of the
people in it are wonderful but for some
reason Jared Leto gave it that secret
sauce I'm giving some Leto love there
you go and I'm like not even I just I'm
like you know what good for like I'm not
I don't even know I'm not even saying
anything good or bad about the shows yes
but I'm like whoa he's like going for it
in a way that is like I do think he is
like seems like a happy person well
remember when the quarantine happened
and and the joke was that Jared Leto
didn't know because he because he was on
a private retreat that's what I mean
like I think he's finding a pretty
groovy balance yeah I don't know there's
if there's I didn't know this but if
there's a person that could be for a
month I think Jared Leto might be one of
them oh yeah just be let out for a month
just walking around that'd be a good
choice
yeah okay
um self-care so you were on your trip
and you read a dirty book no I read a
book called
my year of rest and relaxation which was
a big book that's what the book is
called yeah it was a big book a couple
years ago and I I truly I was like well
I've never read this book and I clearly
I just picked it because I felt like I
needed rest and relaxation that's so
funny and it's about a woman that's so
depressed that she does not leave her
apartment for right like months and
months yeah they didn't switch there but
it did make me laugh she had been called
bummer I know it was it was a weird
choice for my vacation but yeah I did
feel like the vacation and really
letting my phone go I had no way message
and in maybe a bad time the show had
just come out yep or maybe the best time
I thought best time for me but I was
technically still I could have been
doing press but I was like I need to end
this for two weeks so that felt like
self-care yes yeah and so now I'm back a
couple weeks trying to get into some
sort of award two weeks two weeks I've
never done that before all the publicist
so that you know what I mean
as a stand-up they they're they're
always having us do things that you're
like I don't think this is actually
moving the needle as much as like
strategic little like do something
that's really going to help not me on my
phone I'm constantly stressing I don't
think that it feels like work it's like
writer's room stuff it's like we're
gonna stay till nine because it feels
like work how about we just write the
script can I just write this yeah we
don't need to stay till night like for
us to feel more like more stress isn't
gonna help anything and to feel like
grown-ups like we want to briefcases and
button down shirts and be like we're out
set a season nine or whatever it is like
why are you turning this into a real job
it's I don't mean Broad City I just mean
yeah I know and why not be efficient and
get to like have life experiences so you
can actually write about something
[__] thank you for [__] you're
well thank you
so silly exactly tell you so your
parents are both artists is that yeah
which one do you like least
well let me ask you nicely which parent
did you get along with more growing up
like did you did not I'm gonna assume we
liked and love each but like I'll tell
you me and my mom it was like this crazy
Alliance that she still has yet to get
over that I left you know what I mean
like there's like a real like I thought
we had a good thing going here and now
I'm here with your dad like this is
weird so I'm just wondering where did
you lean
I don't know I think I went back and I
literally went back and you're insulated
yeah well I think I I have a really good
relationship with relationships with my
parents
I think I might be more like my dad
in what way like
um
kind of like doing a lot of different
things and
um interest like I want to write this
thing and I'd love to like do like draw
like like just like lots of different
interests but then on the flip side I
tend to be a little set in my ways and
and
I am also kind of a homebody which my
mom is
um
I don't know my mom so growing my mom
was a Potter
and would sell her work at UH uh like
craft shows and then my dad is a graphic
designer environmental graphic designer
and my brother works with my dad now but
that just given you a little bit but my
parents got divorced when I was 13.
rough age yeah rough age rough age
because you were like
really aware of what was going on yeah
yeah it was yeah and then my brother is
like I love sorry yeah
it really was thanks for mentioning it
really was but we also it was also sort
of
fully Jewish but not uh the typical
Jewish Family were like we weren't
talking
like I fully knew what was happening but
it was very much like not talked about
right the divorce yeah is that like a
how is that Jewish no no I not we're not
Jewish in that I think
maybe stereotypically like Jews are more
like vocal about yes and like more like
therapy like and overly open yeah
that way as much I imagine just like
saying what you're thinking in real time
I don't think it's very waspy let's put
it the other way it's very waspy to be
like your mother and I need to have a
discussion you know what I mean yeah I
don't think I think we weren't wasn't
that formal but it was I think a little
bit more waspy interesting yeah so it
was happening and you weren't super
aware of it it was sort of just like
um I was aware and then it was happening
brutal and then like not much talk about
it you have to put down your parents but
that's just brutal
furniture and then they were doing what
they yeah like I was fine I said I was
fine so you're you know yeah I think
they they were doing the best they could
and and I will say to your earlier
question about like who'd you get along
with better so my brother is four years
older she were never in school together
and so he was like home for like a year
and then went to college and then it was
just me and I switched houses every
Sunday
for five years
no no yeah five years so so you'd spend
a week
yeah and then the next Sunday you'd go
back yeah is that standard divorce
protocol I think it I think it's that or
you stay at one house and then you go
for a weekend or whatever and I was
really close with both my parents and so
this is me
being finding the Silver Lining right
now which is what I think I tended to do
as a kid but I got to know them
individually
way better than I think I would have
if they were together because it was
like me and my mom yeah and then me and
my dad oh my God so it was like truly
like us like if I spent in a very
different way I'd be like what you like
like I'd figure something out and like
us cooking and us doing this and because
I only knew them as a dynamic exactly
it's a unit yeah and I there's something
kind of great about it but it also
sounded like maybe it was Whiplash yeah
I mean my the way my life is now can be
directly pinned to that I like to split
my time between New York and la like a
truly I'm trying to do that still and
I'm like my therapist was like why do
you think you're doing that like I'm
truly mimicking tapping a picture yeah
yeah like I'm like I live in I thrive in
chaos yeah in a way you probably don't
like the feeling of a cruising altitude
no it makes me uncomfortable how does
that work you're in a long-term
relationship does that show up yeah it's
something we we literally no in a great
way we literally talked about this
yesterday the fact that
the chaos and how we both sort of
like I I feel like even anyone in this
industry whether you're working or not
it is chaotic you do not know
nothing is stable oh no you know so it's
just like Pirates we occasionally meet
in like a shanty bar yeah and we go out
to see and you look we're meeting in a
port and you're going I bagged A League
of Their Own and I go the Remake how
dare you
it's a reimagining then I make you walk
the plank yeah I'm just kidding but like
I I'm totally with you yeah it's one of
the reasons why I like being one of the
reasons why being married and basically
I'm also a homebody pretty boring boring
is not the right word
I find it peaceful yes peaceful steady
yep is because my my work is so nuts
yeah I feel the same way I love
even if I'm trying to like split my time
somehow yes the
I do feel
I do feel it like I want to say boring
too but it just like
I wanna read yes or I want to just like
be at home because the rest is so you
just made me wish I was at home I'm
having such a great time I really am but
I just said to somebody last night I was
like I'm so glad there's a social
component to my work I did set sets last
night doing this with you right now and
I'm like if I didn't have a compulsive
addiction good addiction to this podcast
to stand up I don't think I think I'd
have jars of urine in my house like I
don't feel yeah it is like because it's
like a high level it's like a manic
energy yes me too in at work and like
right in a writer's room you like you
are you are paid to be on it's truly
like turn on because you gotta like
churn out
you're spewing ideas that's right and if
you do not do that then you're not
that's like the job is spewing out
editing this then we're going to do this
like four years like for it's like so
then when I'm not working I want just
like yes and that that does also make
sense because I'm trying to map it back
on but like that chaos feels very
natural to me moving back and forth
being sort of like stressed and not
knowing why and I'm gonna yeah
it's not often that I hesitate to say
something I share almost everything on
this podcast but I think this is fair my
family life growing up was chaotic in
the same way I didn't know which version
of my parents I was going to get in the
very same way you don't know which Show
Business you're gonna get yeah like you
know when you pitch something and they
buy it and you're like oh I got happy
dad today like that's how it feels and
if you do something and it goes badly
you're like uh dad was in a bad mood
today and then you don't even know
you're like wait how did it go though
that's right like you pitch and you're
like they seem this way but they didn't
and then or like well they want to make
it but like in they really didn't seem
like that yes like you're it's truly
that anything goes were you I'll I'll
say what I experienced in my Youth and
one and but know that I'm telling it to
see if it was similar for you is like
I felt like the the Jason Bourne I mean
you know how Jason Bourne in those
movies is like he always knows where the
exits are and yeah you know he like I
was watching my mom be upset by
something my dad said and my dad is like
eating peas and I'm like he doesn't know
he doesn't know he just upset her and
like I can like reading I don't want to
make myself sound like a genius I'm just
being a hyper sensitive person a highly
sensitive person which I still am it's
one of the reasons why anyway it's like
reading body language because you like
constantly yes you have to everything
not just when is a good time to ask for
a phone in your room which I really
wanted 90s but like private line I had
one I didn't have a private line but I
got one for my birthday one year it was
like my yeah at which house though
at my mom's
I only had the private line at my mom's
I mean if I'm your dad I'm getting two
lines no I didn't have it you can put
one on my own conference all the 90s
stuff
but like it wasn't just like when is a
good time to ask for something but like
I just want to be able to digest my
dinner you know what I mean yeah I know
by the way a lot of people had it worse
I'm just dealing with tensions that's
fine I'm just throwing a bone to the
people that are like listen all relative
like I agree Everything's Relative like
yeah everyone's
childhood trauma is very it's theirs yes
it's theirs but I don't know if it's
uniquely Boston But like everyone I grew
up with you can't get them to complain
about their childhood because they're
always like well they didn't you know
put cigarettes out on me yeah totally
yeah but they did leave you in the car
for nine hours or whatever it is yeah
yeah whatever it is like your [__] is
your [__] I'm glad you said it I usually
say it I'm totally with you thank you so
is this where you started to develop for
lack of a better term like Talent like
you started to get like mimicking
noticing hyper attention I mean how much
of what we do is going like and then mom
is like this and you can kind of talk in
their voice but it's because you were
paying attention I think I was very
observant as a kid and very like
maybe because of some of this like very
much
on my own like I was very good at I
would I drew a lot as a kid even before
that and that is because they both are
in our world and I that's great because
I'm always worried that Leela won't like
being silly or that's her my daughter so
they both liked art and you liked it too
cool yeah and it was like
it was very like part of like my like
birthdays and stuff was like art
supplies and just because that that was
like
I don't know that always felt better
than I mean now I hope kids are still
getting art supplies and stuff because
it's so like screen but but the infinite
potential of a blank piece of paper yeah
isn't it the best it's the best and that
would like occupy so much of my time as
a kid and I don't think I came to
perform and stuff until later like my
parents were my grandparents were very
funny and I started to I was obsessed
with SNL and I would kind of mimic that
them not people yeah I would mimic SNL
characters who did you latch to
um Mike Myers of course and Gilda Radner
yeah and just like I was just obsessed
and my parents were obsessed with us and
all like fun my parents
would I didn't know this but my parents
smoked weed and like I had no idea that
they were smoking meat and wheat like
every once while I would stay up and
watch or I would be doing something and
they would be hysterical
and I thought I was just making them
laugh
and their slurred was high and like it's
so sweet because they're just home with
us yes and they're not like high in an
irresponsible
yeah but it's so sweet now to be like
we're also really high but that also
gave me confidence
isn't that such a I yeah I had a lot of
feelings but from that I don't know I do
know why but let's keep going yeah and
then I didn't get go really into
performance like I did a little bit in
middle school and I was I felt funny
I used to
um do uh like we had
um homeroom like student council
homeroom reports I don't know if you had
this as a kid where there'd be like
student council representative in your
homework yeah and you would like once a
month go to the meeting and you'd come
back to your Homer and like talk about
what was going on in school and I always
did it as Linda Richmond which is coffee
talk
and then my teachers loved it and it was
almost like happy
the that validation from the adults yes
I was like oh but then I went to Art
School
I I didn't know and I don't know about
you but like I didn't know anyone that
did anything in this world art no no
like Hollywood like writing acting like
so this was like not even on the menu no
I was like what I love performing for
school at school but like what the [__]
am I gonna do I'll say for me it was
Matt Damon and Ben Affleck I know that's
silly but they were a little bit older
than us and they won Oscars and we were
like and wrote it themselves all of that
I was like who did it for you
oh
who did that because I didn't come to it
until Davis Rosie O'Donnell
no I mean I don't I I gotta say like
maybe Gilda yeah I read Gilda's book her
autobiography
like when I was a kid I was really did
deep Dives on Gilda Radner yes and I
watched Guild alive a lot which aired on
Comedy Central have you seen Guild alive
no it's great Mike Nichols directed it
like Paul Schaefer is her musical like
it's great it's like if you love Gilda
on SNL it's like she does all these
characters but it's on Broadway
um
maybe that I don't know and then but
when you went to Art sorry yeah when you
went to Art School it wasn't as warm is
that what you were getting to you said
you did your homeroom report and
everybody was dying and the teachers
were laughing and then he said and then
I went to art school and then I mean and
then I went to art school because I was
like well I'm not gonna be a performer
like but in high school you had to sing
to act
and I didn't feel like I could do that
and so I ended up going to art school
because I could I could see
like you can see if you're good at that
or not I could draw yes I was I was
gonna do it alone yeah and my brother
went to Art School who's older than me
my dad was a graphic designer my mom is
a Potter I was like this is being a
successful artist even though that seems
just as hard it felt more attainable
because I was like wow I can do this
here and see that it's good and looks
like this and that felt way more
uh I don't even know
yeah and I could think this way and I
was like excelling in my art class at in
high school and I think it's because you
you and I both know that there are
Potters artists and graphic designers
that you have you and I haven't heard of
but there's no one who's successful in
Show Business that we haven't heard of
right you know what I mean like yeah
they have to like get on the board yeah
and it just felt it felt like when we've
all been a graphic design like I just
didn't
I didn't feel like I could
I guess I always was like I want to be
on SNL but it didn't totally feel
possible yeah and then when I was in
college
I would take this bus up to New York
going to college in Baltimore at this
school called Micah Maryland Institute
College of Art and go up to New York all
the time and I minored in video and then
I started to be
a little bit more
like
everyone's talking about what maybe I
could figure this out or like go to
acting school yeah comedy and acting I
think not even I had comedy was like
childhood and then I felt like I was
good at it but then I really wanted to
go to acting school
so I applied to the Atlantic Theater
which is like Mammoth and William H
Macy's School in New York and I got in
and so I went to this Conservatory after
college for
a week
because
um it was so it is a two-year
Conservatory like dramatic or a one week
and I it's a one week to New York after
I graduated from college and started
this thing you know so this is what I
wanted to do I want to really be an
actor and I hated it more than
I think anything I've
I felt so I was completely stiff and
numb it's not how my mind worked it was
like
scene study analyzing a scene analyzing
like beat word by word and I I can't I
couldn't and then my roommate it was
taking what you love as like a
free-flowing silly like like how you
made Broad City in the moment figuring
it out on its feet and turn it's like
what we were saying about writer's rooms
yeah and no disrespect to that process
it's just not for me either like what do
you mean look when you say but ellipses
what do you think that ellipses yeah
really okay shut the [__] up talking
about analyzing it before it comes out
of your mouth so that when you're ready
when it is gonna come out of your mouth
like how could you ever
it's just not how my brain is oh no and
my roommate at the time who was someone
I went to college with and I had done
video work in college and really it was
just characters it was fully adjust
characters like SNL stuff yeah but
projected on a gallery wall so it felt
serious at college she was like have you
ever heard of this place at the UCB
upward citizens okay and I had not and I
went one night by myself
on 28th
the ridge yeah and
um
was just blown away yeah like I'd never
seen anything like that before because
it was exactly what you were going
exactly and I was like this I don't know
I honestly was like I have no idea what
they're doing yeah in the best way but I
it's all I wanted it's like seeing the
The Lost Boys you know what I mean yeah
I'm I'm projecting onto you my
experience yeah when I saw improv I was
like there are other boys and girls yeah
yeah you're like it's just awe and it's
just I want to do whatever they're doing
that looks so engaging and so and this
is where you meet Alana right yeah and
then I just I quit Atlantic how did you
do that okay we have to take a small
break yeah yeah I'm not going to do the
ads in front of you but we're going to
go to the ads I want to know how you
quit yeah I'm picturing you handing a
resignation to David Mamet which you're
gonna have to tell me if I'm wrong he
runs the day-to-day apartment yeah yeah
yeah because he calls it the [__] day
today yeah yeah uh and then I also want
to get into you into UCB and all that
but we're just going to take we're back
in two minutes
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at every plate fall is finally here
which means back to routine back to busy
schedules and back to the best time
saving hack for weeknight dinners I'm
talking about every plate at first I was
skeptical skepticable about uh meal kits
thinking they were overpriced so
expensive but now with every plate I'm
convinced you can get the same
deliciousness at a lower price a much
lower price in fact and now the quality
of life goes right through the roof Val
and I are cooking together making these
meals together cooking them for me for
Lee uh for her sitting down like a
family feeling good and eating delicious
delicious stuff if you think meal kits
are too expensive think again every
plate is 25 cheaper than grocery
shopping 25 percent cheaper and they
make it fun and they make it easy so
don't turn to take out when things get
hectic instead get every plate delivery
it's 58 cheaper than your average fast
casual meal and you can always feel good
about what you're eating plus you get in
the kitchen which is so good for your
digestion you you smell and you see what
you're making and it starts the process
and then you feel this great feeling of
satisfaction when you're plating it and
eating something that you prepared It's
a Wonderful way to bond with the family
and it's a wonderful way to make it an
event and an activity with no stress and
without breaking the bank every Plate's
quality ingredients come pre-portioned
to help you save money and honestly
reduce food waste you know like that big
bag of spinach you throw out every week
because it starts to turn into liquid
they start getting dark dark green and
sticking to the bottom you know what I'm
talking about so when your weekdays and
nights get jam-packed every plate will
help you get delicious meals on the
table without breaking the you can skip
your week your weekly trip to the
grocery store as well so this is win win
I'm actually counting like 12 wins here
so uh if you get your first box for just
149 that's a dollar 49 per meal by going
to everyplate.com and entering code
weird149 because it's a dollar 49 per
meal which is crazy get started with
every plate for just a dollar 49 per
meal on your first box by going to every
every plate every plate.com and entering
code
weird149 and that's up to a hundred and
ten dollar value
it's crazy thank you every plate for
your support of this show this episode
is also brought To Us by our friend at
mint mobile after years of fine print
contracts and getting ripped off by big
Wireless providers if we've learned
anything it's that there's always a
catch always a catch when it comes to
mobile service so when I first heard
that mint mobile offers premium Wireless
starting at just 15 bucks a month I
thought well what's the catch but after
talking to them and finding out more
about their service it all makes sense
there isn't a capture there isn't one
mint Mobile's Secret Sauce is that
they're the first company to sell
wireless service online only that means
they cut out the cost of retail stores
and pass those sweet sweet savings
directly to you I mean 15 bucks that's
crazy if you swap you could be saved I
mean 60 crazy amounts of bread is what
I'm saying and 15 bucks is incredible so
for anyone who hates their phone bill
mint mobile offers premium Wireless for
just 15 bucks a month mint mobile gives
you the best rate whether you're buying
for one or for a family and at mint
families start at just two lines two
lines for a family that's awesome and
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text and high-speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5G Network so you
can use your own phone with uh with any
mint Mobile plan and keep the same phone
number along with all of your existing
contacts switch to Mint mobile and get
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month so if you want to
get your new Wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get the plan shipped
to your door for free and show your
support of the show go to mintmobile.com
weird that's
mintmobile.com weird cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com
third
we're back right now okay so
we're back we're back we're back for us
there was no Break
um how did you quit that Conservatory
because I mean this is a big deal your
parents had to be paying for it or were
you paying they were
I was very lucky my parents paid for
College college yeah I think that I was
paying for this okay that makes it
better
I think I was paying like now I'm like
either way it I ended it when I ended it
because I would have lost so much money
oh you were in it like it was like it
was like you can take it if you quit
before this time you won't lose your
deposit you just get it back I can't
wait to quit with you and so I was it
was a mess I was like hysterical on the
street in New York which at some point
happens to everybody that lives there
chemistry and I was like I need to quit
now or I will lose the bulk of this it
would be it would have gone past the
week or whatever yeah and so I went in
and just it was one of those scary
I was like I can't do this I guess I
can't be an actor
and maybe I'll do this other thing that
I wasn't sure what that trajectory was
wait you had seen UCB they'd seen it but
that helped yeah you started the other
relationship before you broke up with
the bad one it was kind of simultaneous
okay
Debbie yeah but but UCB wasn't it's not
like you go on and perform on that stage
right away you are it's like signing up
for a class yeah oh yeah and so who was
your so you signed up I signed up who
taught your level one
um Zach Woods he taught my level three
yeah we were there around the same time
yeah this was 2006. I actually you're
reminding me all of 2006. I remember yes
so I was there yeah hearing about
Broad City
sometimes seeing Alana do some like
she did these like uh this is not the
Alana conference
I mean Alana was way more stand-up than
me so you your paths probably would have
crossed in that world yeah that's right
and she did these things where she was
wearing like like a work like a like an
80s workout thing almost like American
Apparel and she was like bend it was
just really like hypersexual it's like
the point of it was like I think making
fun of how hypersexual American Apparel
was because yeah so she was like bending
over orgasmically but it was very funny
but it was also very sexual and I
remember being I was very Christian and
weird and being like who's this young
lady like I was the person that she was
freaking out like people like me but I
remember her at that time but I don't
think our path is crossed but I remember
hearing tell of you guys we yeah so I
mean we were just UCB for a long time we
started doing Broad City and
2009. okay but before that I mean it was
just like day jobs and I have UCB
classes and I was doing some more
character stuff and she was doing more
stand up and we met in a Practice Group
uh
Bobby Moynihan was our coach oh wow and
I'm like he was our coach when he got on
SNL and he kept doing it well it was
like I just he was our coach and he was
like oh God like this the second
audition like freaking like he was like
telling us week by week of what was
going on and then when he got it you
know it takes a while
it's like he would he would have gotten
it like in May and then it would have
started in August so he was like I have
to go I'm gonna go and it was like so
exciting wow I remember he said when I
always forget this guy's name Don Pardo
the announcer yeah said his name that
backstage you just started weeping
which I thought was that was so sweet so
sweet yeah he was great um but we were
on a team practice team I didn't know
that was in two years you got on a
because I didn't know at UCB like
basically we you would pay and a coach
and you would pay for a space like once
a week this is what I did in Chicago
yeah because UCB was such a hard nut to
crack yeah and every time I auditioned I
would [__] the bed like I just they'd
make you audition sorry but I I'm gonna
stick with my words they'd make you
audition with people you didn't know
yeah so you're improvising with eight
other sweaty white guys yeah and like
and I would all just do poorly because
everyone's going like I'm gonna make the
big play right and you don't know you
just there's not that trust if you could
like sign up with a friend that was
always ideal but I couldn't crack it
either I mean that's the whole reason
why we started Broad City I was obsessed
with UCB all I wanted was to get on that
stage and like could not never
get on those teams or anything and so
Alana and I were like should we just
like make something
and so that was
what we did but the Practice Group we
would perform I mean that was so fun on
this group yeah me and Alana in this
group her brother Elliot
um yes Tim Martin
I don't know if you know let me do a
take each way and we'll edit it
accordingly oh yeah Tim no no I don't
know Tim I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding but what if I do I'm so funny no
I don't know if you would know Tim
anyway like he is the one that
introduced Alana and I but we would
perform at like under Saint Mark's
theater like little black box theaters
where you'd rent the space and like give
shots to the audience to like get them
it was just like a very fun time yeah
that's really great never getting on one
of the house teams at UCB and that was
very much
the uh
what is it called the like impetus yeah
to start our own thing yeah those
Gatekeepers can be good for the people
that are there at the beginning when the
gate is first being put up and then it
actually becomes like this bottleneck
that even great people
it's it's not even a UCB thing or or
other places thing just the nature of
Gatekeepers then they just start keeping
out more people than they let and
there's never going to be enough space
for everybody and if you're a little bit
different yeah you're not going to fit
into like the formula of like a Herald
team or whatever well I know this sounds
absurd now and isn't that fun but like a
two lady team in 2009 would have been
kind of like okay not not full okay but
it wasn't exactly like like correct me
if I'm wrong this was still when most
people going to an improv show were
expecting nine white guys and a girl yes
right and so we knew going in was like
okay the slots for us
are so few yeah
and
um also we were both just like kind of
different like Alana wasn't as OBS she
was it really into improv but
I was like obsessed with improv and
Alana I mean what we do what we ended up
doing at Broad City is not
improv so it was it was more it was
always based on our Dynamic so we were
never doing like we would never have
really done a two-person improv show
because our
what we ended up finding was just sort
of like these two Amplified versions of
us and then we can improvise within that
context of the situation we're laying
out or like the scripted episode but we
were never like on our team we were good
and fine but that was never like our
goal was to like go on for us to be like
all these different characters
necessarily
but there were like um Nicole buyer was
uh her her team uh with Keisha and uh
sashir were really popular there were
like women doing not Herald stuff but I
I know what you mean it's just that
seems like the new normal like you'd be
like of course it's like uh this or this
or this but very much in 2009 that's
about when I left in 2010 so it was
still
it was it was unconscious meaning I
don't think we knew we were doing it but
that's what was happening you were an
outlier if you were two ladies
um and did you guys become super close
friends right away is there some funny
story that you went to at KFC there was
also a Taco Bell and you stayed there
all night or something like what is the
story the story is
um just so this guy Tim Martin brought
Alana on YouTube yeah
brought Alana on to our practice group
that I'd we'd been going Lenin Parham
was sometimes our coach for them in the
beginning yeah yeah oh yeah she's the
best and so Tim had brought these two
new players Alana and Elliot her brother
onto the team that night and I was so
confused because I really thought that
Alana was
Alia shakat who played maybe on Arrested
Development you thought it was her I
didn't know I didn't know what that
actress's name was real in real life you
just thought it was maybe because they
they really look alike my God I never
put that together but they really look
alike and so I thought and I'm gonna add
to the mix one of the people in She-Hulk
looks enough like her that I was like is
that just for a second I don't even know
maybe
Tatiana all I saw was a preview it might
have been at a gas station
maybe but I
bet yeah which is what happened and I
also like
I didn't know her real name and I I
Arrested Development the original one I
just it ended and I was about maybe she
moved to New York and would be in the
comedy scene here by the way someone I
know took a clown class and what's her
name oh yeah Alia was in that class oh
so there you go so like exactly like it
might have been a lot I don't think yeah
it's so funny I thought it was her too
you assume everyone makes that mistake
and so
we went to McManus yes which is where
the UCB community and like just the com
it's one of the bars that the comedy
community at least used to hang out in
and we went there that night and we were
at the bar and Alana and I were just
like heading off we're the only two
girls on this team
and
the more she talked
she was like I'm from Long Island and we
ended up having a friend in common and I
was like this is not the girl
like this is not the girl from Arrested
Development you were slowly putting yeah
together the girl but I really love this
girl Alana yes and she was so
I can't you know just sew all the things
that make Alana unique just very
bold and opinionated and hilarious and
just like really felt very different to
who I was at the time which is what we
ended up amplifying so I was always a
little bit shy or a little bit more
insecure doubtful of like why I was even
trying to do what I was trying to do and
Alana had this
sense about her that felt like she
really knew who she was and that is sort
of like the seeds of these two
characters yes yeah and by the way who
wouldn't feel that way with a lot like
that what a great wild card and then
you're like well I'll just kind of tone
myself down a couple notches and we'll
have a nice Odd Couple going on but it
was it was
on this team for two years before Broad
City and that was just this our Dynamic
like we just made each other laugh so
we're very much we're very alike both
have older brothers both
Jewish both more culturally Jewish than
religious and I don't know we just this
Dynamic was just cracked both of both of
us up and then when we were both really
frustrated with our careers what if we
just did something else what if we made
this thing that was like tangible yeah a
little bit like I was talking about well
I could draw and I could see I could
draw like we were trying to do these
shows and we're like What if we made a
thing that was like a thing you could
send yeah and it was like a piece of
something that would auditioned for you
exactly exists when you like something
that's like like doing a web series or a
video or whatever it's out there walking
around even when you're asleep yeah
whatever yeah and it gave us control
over something give us agency
um in that we could
no one we couldn't we were auditioning
for commercials just couldn't get
anything like you know what let's just
do this yeah invest like we were so
broke we also work next to each other
where well I worked at a bakery called
bird bath and Lucia and yellow my name
for a bakery isn't that where birds poop
or bathe okay they bathe yeah I poop in
the bath so I I don't know what's going
on yeah sorry I'm confused I'm always
bathing in the toilet and then I take a
big dump in the tub yes usually but um
yeah
um why are they always covered in bird
[__] yeah
they're not uh go on I worked at this
Bakery sorry we had started Broad City
the web series and I worked at a bakery
which is the City Bakery
in New York had these offshoots called
bird bath I worked at one of those and
one of our best friends Lucia and yellow
who now does the show hacks and who was
a EP and one of them our main director
of Broad City later on had worked at
this company called life Booker which we
were in The Craze of like Groupon type
businesses and that was another one of
those
um Luchia got this job and then got
Alana a job like a week later or a
couple weeks later and then got me a job
and so we I was sitting next to Alana
and we were doing we were making Broad
City the web series and sort of you know
every episode we were paying like our
director like 100 bucks or like paying
the pizza shop to stay open an hour
later to let us shoot in the back 50
bucks and like bringing Bagels to
everybody like it was so DIY wow yeah
because that was our stories are very
similar to keep it brief I was
frustrated not being able to get in
certain places certain Gatekeepers doors
closed and then I've told the story
before but I noticed people like Aziz
were making human giant videos and all
that sort of stuff
but like the thing that I found to be
really I knew for a long time and it was
like a pretty
frustrating time of my life where I was
writing sketches and I wanted to do them
but I didn't know who could edit and
shoot and who had equipment and who had
lights and stuff and until I met Oren
Brimmer who does everything and we still
work together but like finding an Orin
or finding a Brendan colehurst you know
like really hard how did you find some I
know you studied video a little bit Yeah
but it wasn't I will again mine were
sort of like a camera and I was doing a
character and then I'd figure out how to
edit a little but I never really trained
in that way so there used to be this
site called the IRC improv Resource
Center that I would go on you know you'd
find out about shows or someone is
looking for a new improv members you
would just like you'd go on there and
they'd be like it was almost like a
little Reddit I'm not familiar with
Reddit I think it's like Reddit neither
am I sort of like a place where you
could just real fast you what yeah I'll
say as I have many times I've said
subreddit I don't know what that means
and then they talk about it but I think
they rated in HTML I don't know I don't
know yeah well it was like that where
like there were like these just like
discussions but also you could post like
something you needed or wanted or get
out it worked yeah and so this guy Rob
Michael Hugo edit that out what that
worked no edit out this guy's name we're
not giving him anything this guy Rob
Michael Hugo posted that he was like
interested in directing and editing and
so I knew him from a class or a Practice
Group and I was like dude we're looking
for that and for the first season abroad
City the web series we did two seasons
he did all of that and then the second
season
we expanded and so we had a bunch of
different directors so like Paul
Briganti who ended up being like SNL's
director
um Lucia
um who else
um
just a lot of directors that are that
really wanted to direct
this and we had no money we would Rob
worked us with us I don't know he had
Cameron
yeah he did yeah he had a camera I mean
we used one of these I mean Canon was it
a happy day there's a leading question
but the first sketch that I shot with me
and Matt McCarthy and Oren and Oren came
and he brought a bounce out like this
light bounce and he had a camera and he
had a tripod and I was just like I could
have cried I was like oh I found the guy
was that a feeling like oh we're finally
plugged in I mean we worked with Rob for
the first season and then it like it
changed a little as like Dynamics do and
we started working with other people and
Rob still was like a part of it but it
felt like
Growing Pains within the web series but
yeah it was it was exciting because also
you know a lot of people that are in the
web series like wanted to be actors and
we needed extras and so it was always
about using the community and I always
found people on IRC it was really bad
someone calling an Uber for for Mikey
it's like that need again in tribe they
talk about how like there's obviously
disadvantages to being living in poverty
but the the need that forces people
together into Community yeah is closer
to our evolutionary history than wealth
will ever be in fact the more wealth you
have you're at higher risk of suicide
and depression yeah and so when you're
telling the story right yeah I mean that
this time we're all racing towards being
depressed and suicidal in a mansion yeah
and like this that time was was so
exciting because it was like hustling to
try and find this stuff and you know
listen I I don't know
the other people involved might have a
different experience of doing this stuff
but we always hoped the intention was
that everyone involved was getting
experience for their real and their what
they wanted to do as well and we paid
them what we could pay them and we would
have these big parties like do you
remember 92y Tribeca yeah which is not
there anymore it's a great space but
we'd have these big parties where we
would screen like a couple episodes and
have a big party and like the directors
would come up and talk and like really
trying to find that Community
um but then you know when we got the
show the TV version was always we were
writing about that time yes so like
having a lot of Warren trying to be
actors and writers but it was always
that hustle yep on the TV version was
about that that feeling of being in New
York in your 20s and trying and doing
like wanting and like finding your
community and all that stuff it's gonna
be the most interesting time of your
life yes that's what crashing was yeah
okay now I've reached the cruising
altitude now I'll tell you a fabricate
mostly true but like exaggerated or
toned down in some cases version of what
it was like Yeah The reason I'm I'm
shining a light on this is like for all
the people watching that are in that
that time when you're like uncertain The
Gatekeepers won't let you in you haven't
found your Alana in your case in my case
my aura and my mat
like that means you're on the same path
we were all everybody has a time where
they're just like this isn't working
yeah but if that means you're in good
company and also I found that though
listen I hope I
I mean I have written about other things
but that was that time was the most
fruitful material for sure resource for
me for sure because you were
you were flapping in the wind yeah and I
mean even looking back on it like I
needed to go through all that what felt
like those shitty hopeless kind of
moments where you're just trying to get
anything like that is most of my
material is from that time absolutely
and I'm not now I'm not forcing it but A
League of Their Own it's not about the
third season of the baseball league it's
about the first season it's about the
running to the train exactly leaving
your life exactly love those stories yes
about the like [__] who am I I feel like
it's always about figuring it out yep
figuring out where you are and once you
have it figured out I mean I'm not set
look to a certain extent I have it
figured out and I love my life I just
don't have a lot I don't have as many
stories about it I don't want to be like
well I went to the Whole Foods and it
they had less kale than yeah like that's
not as interesting as like we'd go to
the Whole Foods and eat the free samples
and leave
always that is
that one yep
or 99 Cents you like you like to you
can't just that's right yep and you just
want to be like you're just some guy you
don't work for This Yogurt Company
you're just you're we're the same team I
know no tell me
I don't want to get into what Val and I
call nasty delicious when you're talking
[__] but I am interested in when going
from web series to TV show
I remember when I got my first couple
credits there's just like a little bit
of a survivor's uh what's it called
survivor's Guild
was there I mean you can't bring all of
these people with you everybody that
went to 92y Tribeca I'm going to say 99
of them couldn't come on the let's not
call it a Lifeboat that's too dramatic
but you got this break how did you
navigate your first success
yeah I mean I'm sure again I'm sure
there are people who
probably hate me or you know without me
intending that or I thought maybe I
handled a situation one way and
and didn't that's just
I just want to say absolutely that's
true for me too yeah yeah absolutely and
so that sucks but I'm I mean I hope it's
not like a vicious hate but maybe like
the situation felt very different for
them than it felt for me
um that's probably inevitable because I
have that with on the other side oh
forget it so talk about Legacy is there
was like I looked at him but there was
also times where I was just like because
these you know what I mean like what is
what is his life there's that was his
business yeah and my business was my
business but like I they become the
symbol of your frustration yeah and I'm
sure and yeah I'm sure that that
what happened
um I think we had worked with so many
people on the web series and then there
was like this big huge time lapse of
us pitching and developing and we were
at FX for a year writing the pilot and
then they passed and then we were like
there was so much time that we hadn't
really been working with anyone
specifically when we were done with the
web series that it felt like crazy to
not like it wasn't
it wasn't like someone we were like bi
at that point
um that's probably good it slows yeah a
little bit and again maybe that there
was messiness in the middle there but um
I think we've we really tried
and not even out of like listen
so many people helped us but they were
peoples whose work we loved so it wasn't
even like we owe them it was like while
we do they did we do owe them and
they're great yeah if that makes sense
so it wasn't like
we're bringing people we're trying to
include people because we feel
oh it was like both it was like
they were part of this and they're
awesome at this so
I was so happy with the the TV show in
um I always felt like it was an
extension of UCB and the comedy
community in New York like you can't
watch an episode without
and Neil was in the pilot uh Neil Casey
Casey yeah and Neil was in Broad City
and just I think in Broad City we
there are so many
New York comedy people in every in the
series right I mean Hannibal we met I
mean Hannibal we had known for a long
time he used to do stand up at shows
where we were doing our improv team
shows Hannibal gemberling uh two of our
Paul I mean Paul Downs uh wrote on the
show as well and Paul Lucia were our
main two collaborators from UCB like
from UCB days like it just felt such an
extension of that community that
actually we couldn't we couldn't perform
on that stage and then I almost felt
like we created a space where we all
could we all could yeah and even even in
League like Don fanelli is uh Darcy
um I mean I've known Darcy for 15 years
I met in a commercial acting class that
no not broken Mary I bet we took the
same one though it was it was someone
I can't remember her name to me all the
time because Darcy has a story Darcy
felt like she said she went home and
told Jason her husband when we took this
class she was like there's this girl in
this class that's great and the teachers
think she sucks
like the teachers just like can't see it
yeah but I I really feel that way where
I'm like I believe in these people like
I think these people are so funny yes so
if I have the power to like cast people
I'm gonna cast the people who I love
working with because I they're fun
in the process and they're great and for
some reason like aren't always thought
of
it's like I wish you would say this so I
could put on the YouTube thumbnail but
I'm gonna say it
if you don't like The Gatekeepers build
your own gate yeah would you say that
I'm just kidding I don't think that we
ever thought that but like we just like
it became that where it was like wow
we're gonna cast
gethard yeah my getherd and Shannon
O'Neill were the two most influential
improv teachers from me and will Hines
like yeah Anthony King ronan's like all
these people who had this edit all of
that out who had this effect on us we're
all in the show yeah yeah take it out
please
um yeah so love it need it again our
lives are very similar because with
crashing I was like one of the reasons
Judd wanted to do crashing was he said
if there's great Comics that don't have
their own show we could do an episode
just about them and I was like oh yeah
we the show kind of went a different
direction but uh we got to cast a lot of
people yeah but you also worked with I
think you sloven worked on your show too
right so everyone was on ours he did you
gotta have Eric sloven I was thinking
about how his wife what's his wife's
name Amy Ryan because she's incredible
yeah and whenever we see her I love them
as a couple so much I've never seen them
as a couple but I we watched the office
kind of all all the time and I'm always
like I can't believe this is no
disrespect to Eric but she's so magical
I'm like I can't believe she's not
married to like George Clooney or
something you know what I mean like
she's just like literally I feel like
there's a movie where she is married to
George Clooney is there I wonder she's
just like that's what I mean she's just
like
one of the grapes one of the great and
so funny funny so funny but they're
great I believe yeah yeah that I hope
that didn't come out like I was like
this bum because Eric is a delight yes
and absolute like shifting gears ever so
slightly
um have you ever seen a ghost
no are you sure would you like to I
don't know I wouldn't either
um what about
this is a this is pretty open-ended but
like has anything in your life happened
that you can't explain that sort of
defies the laws of of reason or like it
just remains confusing to you a couple
examples would be you know certainly a
ghost a UFO an alien uh you went to a
psychic and they told you this this or
this anything unexplainable and no is
fine
hmm
or synchronicity
oh I mean I do feel I don't have an
example but I feel like
some synchronicities I'm very aware of
synchronicity yeah and love when it
happens me too but I can't think of one
no I wouldn't ask you to but like they
but they're like breadcrumbs they're
like we must be on the right path yes
speaking of God what happened last night
they happen so often to Val and I as a
couple not to say we're like this
magical pixie couple but we sort of are
how annoying but like we'll be talking
about
it has to be something really obscure
like uh t-ball isn't obscure enough but
let's say it's t-ball like we have a
long conversation about t-ball and then
that night we're on my YouTube which of
course is all like weird mystical stuff
and religious lectures and stuff she's
like what's that one and I click on it
and the guy will talk about t-ball for
like five minutes and we're like that's
enough and I'm like Val you that just
happened two nights ago I'm like you
picked it like that's so [__] I'm
actually being more excited than I even
am in the moment because I'm just like
that's just how it goes yeah are you and
you're by the way this isn't like I'm
not trying to get it dirt or anything
I'm interested in your relationship
aren't you engaged I am engaged hey
congratulations are you super excited I
am really excited we haven't planned
anything great because you know it's
trouble when everything's planned and
like it's just like like a business the
like Yeah The Wedding business I was
just like oh like it's so exciting and
we're so excited when we we keep like
having like okay what do you want to do
and it's just like
I think we're both so excited to be
engaged also and it's okay not to
there is a pressure just because it's
like oh if you want to get married at a
place that's actually like a traditional
wedding venue it's like a year out
that's why there's this pressure but
I think at this point it's only been a
couple months that we've been engaged so
it's still just exciting I didn't know
how did you get engaged we got engaged
and I'm not I might not tell this whole
thing we got engaged she was in London
you're like well David Blaine yeah David
Blaine wasn't there we were we were in
London she was shooting she's going to
be on the upcoming season of Ted lasso
oh fun yeah and we were in London and
um it happened there
cute she waited until it turned six
o'clock on Big Ben and the ring was on
the the sixth it fell and you went she's
like just keep holding your hand like
this okay I don't know what and then
Jason Sudeikis walked by one now that's
an engagement and you're like oh my God
yeah I couldn't believe she got him and
she's like he charged me fifty thousand
dollars he did no friends we can't
afford the wedding anymore but Val would
say were she here
um a wedding planner will remove thine
fear I know I'm just kidding like a
wedding planner you just like haven't
it's been like such a oh don't even
worry about it summer but that is the
you know what is reminding me of ABS is
is your approach to acting and
creativity
and and Val is Val got excited about
planning not in the
uh what is the typical gender typical or
whatever whatever it is like oh the lady
can't wait she just like she kept saying
I'm gonna say this to you and see what
you guys do with it it's like she wanted
to invite people to a space that looked
like our love so it was a very warm
wedding yeah safe it was kind of feels
like you just want to create an
experience that can
celebrate this thing that feels like you
guys and you're inviting them into it
and there really is something just as
primates as mammals it feels good I'm
just excited for you
to invite other bodies into a space that
feels like you guys yeah and then say
hey we love each other and we just want
you to hear that I know that's this
whole thing especially and I I really
love weddings and you also feel when
you're at one that's good is like that
good and it doesn't have to be like
exactly what I would want yeah in in the
way of like it's a good wedding it's
just like wow that feels like them yeah
and I'm so I feel happy that I was there
to witness that and once you're married
uh you might already understand this as
having been in a relationship but like
especially when you're married you go to
another wedding it's like point zero two
percent your wedding renewed because
you've gowns and you cry and you're like
I still feel it and then you're like and
there are other couples that are like
but that's wonderful and
um sorry but it seemed like you skipped
over the engagement story so why don't
you tell them
you did I know he did that's okay I'm
excited and please
you already said it I have no advice I'm
just echoing what you already said which
is just enjoy being engaged yeah what's
the rush I know the only Rush is that
it's it's it is like also exciting yeah
you know it's like the Russian the same
way that like Supermarket Sweep there's
a rush yep love that one
I love revisiting that oh my God it's on
Netflix I believe I know it's it's a
hoot with the ham
grab the ham John Ham too just grab them
if you see them it's okay he won't mind
um so nothing unexplainable other than
synchronicities have you ever oh it's
okay zero people ask me sometimes fans
will ask me questions that I ask and
they're like what is that and I go I got
nothing I I can't I can't answer my own
questions so please don't uh feel bad
um have you ever almost died that one's
easier
I would note this would be top of Mind
wouldn't it you would know sometimes
it's when you were a kid uh I don't
think I had a like major
okay almost death that's all right yeah
that makes me nervous like it's like
yeah this is your final destination no
most people have one
really good one occasionally you get one
I remember Taylor Tomlinson's was like I
wish you hadn't told that story like it
was like like a terrifying like a scary
one we're looking for like I got caught
by the riptide
[Laughter]
well
um you mentioned your cultural Judaism
from the tribe of Judah
[Laughter]
where are you now know that you're in
the safest place possible
um so it's an agenda free but like
and I really mean now like Abby today
here we are
conscious alive alive at the same time
[__] crazy live at the same time is
like
Ruby McGuire like just like
I haven't thought about that that I
might that that we are alive at the same
time as Toby McGuire just a toss pillow
I had to I couldn't think of a of a more
Dynamic answer
um but like
it is confusing and none of us are
talking about it really and I know there
are easy answers but they're easy
answers on both sides of the spectrum
where are you at when it comes to the
meaning of life
um one way at it is do you think death
is the end do you have any deity or any
any framing device just what comes to
mind hmm
no it's so nice to I don't often stop
and think about this and I feel like I'm
not as spiritual right now as I feel
like I am interesting I know that
feeling and that might be also the way
I'm feeling of like this I'm just like I
don't have a lot of time yeah
even the vacation felt like
I was intentionally
putting time like over here to do the
vacation right but I feel like I the
rhythm of what I want my life to look
like normally would have more space for
that and like that just kind of means
more quiet yep for me
um yeah I do feel really
again culturally Jewish I I mean I had
about Mitzvah as a kid and
I do feel connected in that way but not
religious I don't go to Temple yeah
they're thinking about that that I miss
and that I feel like would be nice is
that community of course but I never
felt that
never felt connected to that Community
as a kid if that makes sense like I
liked the Gathering on high holidays and
things like that but it those actual
people in that room didn't feel
necessarily like the community
um I just want to say same yeah and so
weird thing it's almost like an
aspirational community in that way but I
do think that that is why I felt so
connected to Alana
and we had this like shared
culturalness to us yeah and I think but
also a displaced feeling from it yeah
because by the way again yanked from my
own experience it turns out
the people the large number of people
that don't feel at home in the community
that your parents probably feel at home
those exiled people are a community
right yeah we just don't have anywhere
to meet yeah yeah exactly we're just
around yeah and then but you can find
them then you find Alana and you're like
like Val her parents are pastors and
stuff and like that was a huge reason
why we bonded was we knew the same
praise songs and we knew but we also had
that same sort of like it's almost but
not quite right yeah and then you look
for it together yeah but I guess for me
spiritually I really feel most connected
when I'm in nature yes like that is kind
of
I think taken
the place of like whatever that I don't
even feel like I felt connected really
religiously as a kid going to Temple yes
it felt like something I was supposed to
do
and now I do feel most connected to
whatever
[Music]
people would call God I don't know if I
I really need to examine it a little
more I'm in a I'm in a moment where I'm
like not sure but I think my
spirituality really is
um
nature yeah yeah what's funny I where
did I get this
I'm forgetting the name of it
it's a vedanta book it doesn't matter it
I mean it does matter but it also
doesn't matter
the the writer makes the point that God
is just a word that means origin yeah
right so it was it's been ruined
certainly over and over and over and
will continue to be ruined that's what
we do with it but when you're in nature
a couple things
one silence is everybody every Mystic
every teacher with their salt will
always say the same thing which is like
there's no greater teacher than silence
and the more
um a custom you are to being with
yourself and being silent and being
still great and they all will say that
nature is a great way to get into that
because I don't know if if you're the
same as me you seem like you are like
we're Achievers we like doing stuff we
like making stuff and then underneath
that drive for me it's it's a
repurposing of anxiety into drive is a
feeling that if I'm not producing I'm
not worthy like I'm worthless
and the great thing about Nate I I don't
really believe that but that's still in
there no yeah yeah it's still in there
we're working on it critically know that
that's not right but that's right yeah
exactly and there was a time that I
critically thought it was right right
um but nature and I've said this a
million but Richard Rohr talks about how
nature is beautiful and asks nothing
from you and there's that's just one of
the things that calms me down yeah like
there's nothing Sinister about this
podcast but you are doing my podcast
like we're having a nice chat but you're
doing my podcast so I am asking
something from you
um again I hope that's not malicious or
gross but at Sunset Abby yeah it's given
you everything and it doesn't even care
if you look at it I mean yeah that is
just like yeah so necessary I think I'm
going to say to people like us
and I I also like the secondary part of
it is like well I think of nature as
like going out and looking at the sunset
or I'm on a hike and you're you're able
to get away from like everything yes but
then going back to your the
synchronicity like that also
I think is when I feel most I mean it's
really just feeling a connection to
this so it's when I'm in nature I really
feel connected and we are
part of Nature and so the
synchronicities that happen maybe not I
mean you could feel it with the t-ball
thing but I think it's like the the
synchronicities that happen when you
where you think of someone and they call
you yeah
or you run you you're you thought of
someone and you you you you go out and
you you're running an errand and like
you you see them yes like thing like
energetically that also feels like the
secondary part of like the nature
where I feel connected where I'm like
okay so like there that's bigger that
like the energy of it all that's right
you're not isolated yeah that's the
whole point everybody knows I'm going to
say this but religion breaks down to re
like to do it again Lee Geo comes from
the same word for ligament so to
reconnect so when you're in nature you
see it you see this
non-resisting thing like I know it's an
extreme example but in a forest fire the
trees aren't like oh no no no no there's
just kind of like it's just kind of
doing what it does including living and
dying same with animals dying by the way
they don't go like what about my things
they just kind of go I've been with my
Gap when it does it just sort of like
goes and there's something
connecting and soothing to go like even
though we have these highly developed
frontal lobes that give us this like
different perspective yeah you're that
yeah you're you're that like when I look
at the stars you're that yeah it's not
what so many of us grew up thinking
which is like you're this thing that was
placed in this world that like walks
around and explores it like an astronaut
right you are a product of it yeah
you're an extension of it right in fact
you're a linchpin holding it all
together and and even your death is
appropriate in the wholeness of it like
because it's not about Abby and it's not
about Pete it's about this one life so I
mean you don't need my validation but I
think that's beautiful I also in the
last yeah maybe last year but I read
that the overstory
it's just beautiful for me Richard
Powers okay it's a beautiful beautiful
book
about trees connectivity really yeah
well one of the favorite my favorite
books I've ever read over story The
overstory
I'm gonna I'm gonna put my phone here
like I'm big into trees well you should
be
Abby why are the most interesting things
the most boring things like trees and
the way that they use spores the so
there's this book right
they're Fascinate and they're all it's
like all connected like it's yeah and
we're that way yeah so when you're
thinking of your friend I know we don't
have the data for this although some
would say we do have the data for this
there's there's interesting
I forget what it's called I think it's
called the science delusion but it's
called something different in America
anyway someone messages it to me there's
this British guy who talks about
the the mythology meaning the beliefs
the unquestioned beliefs of Science and
and one of them is is things like if
Abby thinks of somebody and then they
calm that's hogwash
uh and meaning we don't have the how
would we measure yeah and it's not yet
agreed upon right but I think there
there will be a time yeah when it is
agreed upon or we'll go into another
Dark Ages who knows
I'm actually not pessimistic I just mean
like that seems to be what's going on
like yeah and then it's like burn the
library you know what I mean
um not I actually didn't even mean that
in a fearful way so I'm going to read
that over story but I think everything
you need to know and not to be too
religious but every time not every time
often when people ask Jesus a question
he would say look look at the trees he
would say look at the fruit of the tree
he would look look at the birds
it's one of my favorite teachings on
anxieties he's like look at the birds
they don't worry about where their food
comes from because they know that
they're part of a system right obviously
you and I need to plan our lunch yeah
probably right around now
[Laughter]
but but the point Remains the point yeah
um well this was a delight is is there
any oh I had one League of Their Own
question
um how dare you I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding I'm just gonna say that one
for the end
um how dare you go back into my
childhood I'm just kidding I was
how old was I when I came out it doesn't
matter when you put on the uniform and
you ran out on the field yeah emotional
yeah putting on you know so the pilot we
didn't wear them
you wore your like a practice uniform
because it's like tryouts right I mean
even that felt emotional just like
because there's a field of women in
old-timey practice care but putting on
the
peaches uniform yeah
um that just felt
bizarre yeah like that made it feel very
real yeah
um and that was a very formative film
for me and just of course what are we
doing we didn't get to this what are we
I don't yeah you know anyway as do you
identify as queer is that the right one
yeah okay so as a queer person was that
movie like I mean I I'm not queer but I
watched that movie and Rosie I'm dying
like I can't like any story whether it's
sexual identity or otherwise about
someone despite the outside world
claiming their truth Moonlight I know
it's another sexual one it destroys me
every time but if you go like I have to
live authentically yeah which by the way
tribe mentions the three things that you
need to be happy one is you need to feel
like you're good at your job one is you
need to feel connected to community but
the third one you might not guess is you
need to feel authentic in your life
great of course but of course but yeah
but how many people do you know that
maybe you went to high school with and
you talk to them and they sound like
they're doing some sort of character I
know I feel like a lot of people don't
feel that yeah that's right yeah so
that's huge so that so tell is there a
little bit
we're sort of at the time if you have to
go uh I completely understand and that's
that's not passive aggressive like if
you want to end this and everyone boos
but I did forget to ask about that and
I'm very interested in like sexual
identity A League of Their Own your own
coming out all that sort of stuff where
does that yeah I mean by when I I
watched that movie and did not and now I
came out in 92 I did not
really clock that yeah it's also not
open for yourself well for myself no at
all yeah
um I didn't come into my that my
sexuality until I was in my early 30s
right like it truly like was not
surprised I'm sorry again even as a
straight person it wasn't until my early
30s that I was like what do I actually
like it turns out it's women but like
like I just was yeah like
I wasn't ever against it and I like
thought I I had like
I'd be like maybe I like should I like
try to like hook up with girls and I was
like I don't think I'm in like I truly
was not I don't know
um and I went to art school I really
feel like it was a missed opportunity
um you know but whatever
uh but yeah I I it so it just
I don't know I don't know also I think
the generation I'm 38 like I just I'm
like
there was like two out people maybe in
my high school it was like we I just
grew up in a time where that was like
not no content about Will and Grace yeah
and then like like truly like there's
nothing so and Ellen was a big deal
remember
she's gay huge deal big deal
Rosie wasn't out when this film was made
and her character is not overtly gay at
all talks about a boyfriend and then
like throws his throws his
picture out the out the window because
he doesn't treat her well right not but
not because no I'm living a lie no it
was not but it is like considered
it's not considered but it is sort of
like was this film that
queer people love because it's just
about I think that
any story that's about a group of people
that are like this like kind of like
they're Outsiders and they found each
other yeah any story where people have
like found their Community that's right
is very especially in the 40s what
you're not supposed to do it yeah I
think that that's why it was so it's
like a queer film but it's not queer at
all yeah but so that was this this that
was part of at least this reimagining
was like this community well that League
The All-American Girls League which is
like where the peaches are which is only
half of the show version was really
queer like a lot of women on that League
work weird doing the research we found
out
like we found more and more that that
was the case and that generation this
generation that we are exploring in the
show version is about a generation of
women playing baseball so it's not just
about the white women or the white
passing women that were allowed to be on
this league it's about what happens when
that door closes for women of color who
were [__] great at baseball where
where did they play and so we're trying
to tell a lot of stories a lot of queer
stories too and so I don't know if I'm
answering your question but I guess I
mean I since I realized this about
myself I've put it into everything I can
just because I put everything else about
myself into stuff so Broad City
I think more than league is like a more
true
version of my experience so like in the
fourth season abroad City Abby meets a
girl
because she smashes her face she like
faints and smashes her face which did
happen to me too I have a scar on my
nose and at the hospital this is not
true but at the hospital like meet the
doctor
she like asks out because she's like
wait the only reason I'm not asking her
out is because she's a woman but like
I'm attracted her and that was exactly
what it felt like for me really where I
was like wait I'm like into this person
but they're a girl like a they were a
guy I would ask them out I was very much
into that at the moment like very much
like vote like just like not in love
with you but like you want to get a
drink and I felt like one the only
reason I'm not doing that is because
she's a woman like that's [__] up
so let me like
let me ask her out and see what happens
yeah and then that's do I have an IRL
yeah and then this person yeah and then
how did that go
it went great for a while and then it
dated that person yeah and then it
didn't
you know and that is also like I'm so
again sort of into what you were talking
about of like uh
that those moments in your life where
you feel like they're like the worst
like me being broken up with and like
heartbroken after that
relationship I was devastated it was a
new and I
it was so essential that too like I'm so
happy
that happened they they broke up with
you yeah I mean I I it was terrible
let's go in there like it was such a
that was like that's what my book is
about in part about just like whoa
figuring this out about myself
that I do I do also like I'm marrying a
woman but I'm like I still would I guess
if I were to label myself more in the
label I know I identify as queer but I
would be bisexual yeah I was like wow I
missed out on like half the population
here and I don't know the way that all
went down and I was like devastated and
heartbroken
um it was so essential to who I am now
so I'm like yep it's um all part of it
it's the forest again yeah it needed to
it needed to burn it needed to burn and
then like regrow and now I'm like wow
yeah yep yep you are nature well
that's pretty wild I love that and I'm
excited for you I think you're gonna
like being weird I like me too it's fun
um but it's a girl right are you worried
about cooties I'm just kidding yeah we
haven't kissed yet so I'm not sure like
I don't know I had to get over that when
you're raised your whole life girls
cooties girls cooties
let me ask you the final question okay
can you tell me a time in your life that
you laughed really really really really
hard
maybe you were on drugs maybe someone
farted maybe someone fell down these are
the these are the options oh I have one
this is I yeah
okay so I'll try to make this quick so I
was in high school and my one of two of
my best friends Sam and Jess
uh we were volunteering
um it's like Halloween and we were
volunteering to scare kids on like a
trail
[Laughter]
like I don't know why it was like they
like needed people to like there was
like a like a Haunted Trail in like this
like Community Center they like needed
people to like volunteer to like be the
people that like scared people anyway we
were doing that and then we also
simultaneously were teens and we're like
there's a party tonight we need to leave
and so we'd committed to volunteering
and then we're sneaking out also like
what were we volunteering it wasn't like
a charity it was like a scare kids yeah
really scare group anyway so we were
like we gotta sneak out of this Trail to
go to the party we really wanted to go
to seniors in high schools
we had like masks and wigs and I think
we were going to my house after to
change anyway so we're running away from
the trail like trying to be
like Sly about it and we finally I was
in the front because I was pretty fast I
was in the front and we were like it was
like from Trail into parking lot like
pavement change like so like the like
blacktop of the of the parking lot like
was like a dip in the yes anyway
sprinting we're like looking back and
like we made it we made it I
trip over the like pavement go down so
hard okay like like like full like down
on the pavement and Jess is right on my
tail
and so she she falls on over me like
trips on me and then Sam like made it
out clear but we were we were dying like
because we'd been trying to get away
quietly and quickly and truly like hurt
ourselves so much leaving this volunteer
like Halloween like it was nuts and like
really hurt ourselves and it was one of
those moments as a teenager where I've
never laughed harder oh
and like like fully
blood like blood like skinned like hurt
every which was very fitting for the
holidays yeah it looked even scarier it
was so messy and you had a wig on it was
like that makes it yeah it was like like
I think I I think I would had a mask so
I like took the mask off but like we
were carrying like the [__] that we had
like dressed up as yeah it was so messy
wow yeah
I love that that's what I'm going to
remember it also reminded me of a bed I
used to have where I was like a lot of
people get hit by cars on Halloween
which is obviously sad and it also has
to be awkward too because for a moment
you're like either they're really hurt
or that's a great costume
great like in action costume my God
yeah yeah
well that looks uh it looks so real
um ABS thank you so much I was very
excited for that and I'm really glad
you've been so fun it made me like think
about a lot of things I'm glad it got
toasty in here we're gonna have to run
that AC next time
you can oh no no that wasn't me being
passive aggressive like Katie you should
have known
um well thank you thank you thank you so
much oh I love Mitchell's versus the
machines actually thank you
like it was like an oscar-worthy movie I
love it they killed it they they killed
it and your performance is great in it
thank you so I'm excited we have the
guests say the catchphrase which is keep
it crispy so in a moment I'm gonna ask
you to say keep it crispy did you do an
affectation on your voice not really so
I sometimes I go a little bit like
I don't know why I felt the need to
finish that sentence for you and I
apologize
[Laughter]
um but so we'll have it as your
character but also as you it's the same
voice it's the same voice
um but because it is technically your
character I owe you a sag uh yes this
will be as Katie so that's right yeah
would you say keep it crispy just to
close us out yeah keep it crispy I mean
great voice keep it crispy a couple
options there
[Music]